Did you predict ln of 3 minus ln of 7? If so, you were right. Let's check out
the values of each of these and see what we get. First, let's find natural log
of 3 over 7. So we press the ln button on the calculator, and then 3 divided by
7. Interesting. We get negative 0.8472, and so on and so forth. Let's write
that down. So, now we've got one side of our equation into number form. Let's
check out the other side now on the calculator. Okay, so we want ln of 3 minus
ln of 7. I've got it plugged in right, so let's press equals. And sure enough,
we get exactly the same decimals we have over here. So, our calculator has
helped us confirm this prediction. ln of 3 over 7 is equal to ln of 3 minus ln
of 7.